[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer
news from Google in the last two
weeks.
Android 7.0 Nougat has
begun rolling out to users.
For more on what's included,
how we're rolling it out,
and what's next, check out the
post linked in the description
below.
There's a new Street View
renderer in the Google Maps
JavaScript API that brings
rendering improvements
and better mobile support.
Street View helps make apps
more unique and exciting
by giving users a sense
of what it's like to visit
a place in real life.
Check out the post for
all the improvements,
including before and
after screen caps.
The open source version
of Google Santa Tracker
has been updated with the
Android and web experiences
that ran last December.
We extended, enhanced,
and upgraded our code,
and you can see how we used our
developer products, including
Firebase and Polymer, by
following the link below.
Check out this post for
highlights from the latest
release of TF-Slim.
The TF-Slim library
provides common abstractions
which enable you to define
models quickly and concisely
while keeping the model
architecture transparent
and its hyper
parameters explicit.
And it keeps getting better.
Also from TensorFlow, we're open
sourcing TensorFlow model code
for generating news headlines
on Annotated English
Gigaword, which is a
data set often used
in summarization research.
Check out the post for
details and the GitHub link.
Stackdriver is great for
troubleshooting issues
in production
cloud applications,
and now it has logs
panel integration.
Not only can you gather
production application state
and link to its
source, you can also
view the raw logs associated
with your Google App Engine
projects, all on one page.
More details and a
screenshot are on the post.
I've got two Google
Cloud Platform updates
for Java developers.
First, the beta
release of two new
build tool plugins,
one for Apache Maven,
and another for Gradle.
These plugins allow you to
test your applications locally
and then deploy them to the
cloud from the command line
interface or through
integration with an IDE,
such as Eclipse and IntelliJ.
And on that note, you can
now use the new Google Cloud
Tools for IntelliJ plugin to
deploy your application in App
Engine standard and
App Engine flexible,
and use Google Stackdriver
Debugger and Google Cloud
Source Repositories
without leaving that IDE.
Here's another bundle of posts
for the Google Cloud platform.
These are about working with
Windows Workloads, everything
from setting up a
Windows server and SQL
server on Google Compute Engine
to cloud tools for Visual
Studio and PowerShell.
Check out all three
posts linked below.
Don't forget to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]